[Music]
sean can you share any updates on your
plans quarterback position this week
no updates mike i'm eating my bagel i
was hoping to be chewing it when you ask
that question what kind of bacon is that
everything bagel or this like sesame
seed
it's a poppy seed steamed bagel which
are hard to find actually
that's sean payton doing everything he
can
to give no information about how the
quarterback reps will be divided between
jameis winston and taysom hill with drew
brees out for at least two weeks
five fractured ribs reportedly collapsed
lung reportedly i assume five days later
the lung is no longer collapsed peter
i'm impressed by sean payton's ability
to put the clamp
on everyone you know we've seen coaches
try to pull this off before where
they're not going to announce any of
their plans at quarterback you'll find
out on sunday well the problem is once
you start showing up at practice and
you've got plenty of people there
and someone's going to say something to
someone and the next thing you know
someone's going to say something to a
reporter and we're going to have the
jameis winston is the starter taysom
hill is the starter they're going to
split the reps whatever whatever they've
been doing to practice two days of
practice now wednesday thursday there's
been nothing that's amazing to me that's
next level
coach putting the fear of coach
into everyone in the building to keep
their damn mouth shut and we still don't
know what's gonna happen
mike there's a reason for that uh
not only i'm sure as sean said everybody
zip your lip which doesn't always work
but
the biggest reason is the media rules
this year
okay
you cannot have personal contact with a
player now
that isn't to say that if you've got uh
let's say
michael thomas's uh cell number that you
don't text him and say hey what's going
on or hey you got five minutes
but but most
this year
i am finding
that a lot of the stories that you
normally might read that would have a
significant amount of depth don't have
that depth to them because you can't
sidle up to guys this year and say hey
what's going on out there and so that is
what is the big difference
sean payton can control this
by when the media portion of practice is
open usually with most places for local
beat people
practice will be open you know 15 20 25
minutes okay and it's very very simple
to control what happens
in those 15 20 minutes let's say and
that is
alternate snaps between jameis winston
and taysom hill
you know have them do exactly the same
thing mirror each other
and you know i read on on wednesday that
that's exactly what payton did
but
mike this
sort of disguises my first thought when
i
saw edward's report the other day about
the injury to breeze i said you know
everybody is going to think that either
it's taysom hill or or jameis winston
probably most people jamis as it turns
out
i do think it's going to be a job share
i'm not saying 50 50. but i think taysom
hill is gonna play a lot
more than he normally plays my gut
feeling is the job is james's at least
you know for now
uh but i think it's going to be a job
share and
if jameis winston turns it over
multiple times
i think uh sean payton basically says
taste them get in there it's your it's
your game
so we'll see what happens i think
sean payton views this as a challenge
too and when you've been coaching as
long as he has and these moments come
around where there's an opportunity to
come up with yeah it's fun it's fun yeah
yeah it's it's new it's different it's
not the same old thing every week now
he's one of the coaches that constantly
challenges himself to find new ideas
find new plays add wrinkles to the
offense but still this is the closest
thing you're going to have to an
in-season tear it down and try to
rebuild it and i'm sure that given the
amount of time he spends thinking
creatively about his offense he's had an
idea as to what he would do this year
you have to have that idea when your
starting quarterback is 41 and he missed
five games last year you have to have
some tentative plan for what you're
going to do if you get into this
position so
uh yeah it's it's probably been a very
fun week for him they're not playing an
opponent that is impossible to beat even
though the falcons aren't as bad as
three and six would suggest
uh it it is going to be fun and that's
how i look at this game it's just kind
of a game that otherwise would have been
i look at it and i think man this is
going to be exciting to see what jameis
winston does the last time we saw him he
was throwing the football into the gut
of a falcons player who took it in for a
touchdown to end the season and end his
career in tampa bay we get to see what
he does against the falcons now we get
to see what taysom hill does we get to
see how they interact with the other
players and what the offense can do and
can the defense hold up and can the
saints keep pace that's the other side
of it as well there isn't much margin
for error for these teams that are at
the top of the nfc you have one or two
bad weeks you go from the top to the
middle of the pack so it's critical
that sean payton finds a way during drew
brees absence to win these games however
it takes
yeah and i think one of the things
somebody uh
close to peyton told me this in the off
season when i asked him about what do
you think of the match between
uh peyton and jameis winston he said
it's going to be fantastic
because
he said jameis will know the bottom line
and the bottom line is
you're not going to turn the ball over
and be sean payton's quarterback period
if you turn it over you can have a seat
next to whoever on the bench
and so that is what is at stake for
jameis winston
you know if people who say yeah he
needed a fresh start after tampa and
needed a new coach and everything like
that well he's got one he's got one of
the best offensive coaches in recent
history and now let's see if he can
resuscitate his career it is all on
jameis winston's shoulders right now
and even though the ultimate grade in
what is pass fail when it comes to a
first round upper tier quarterback is
fail for jameis winston
there were periods where
he was looking pretty good i remember in
2016 a second season there was some mvp
chatter they had a great run that
culminated in a sunday night game that
was actually flexed to prime time
buccaneers at cowboys
and that's when it all fell apart in
2016 but he's had his moments and even
though he had plenty of interceptions
last year he threw plenty of touchdown
passes as well and he had a decent
completion percentage and i think peyton
manning are not peyton manning sean
payton peyton payton they know who we
mean sean payton will be in a good
position to get the best of jamis and
minimize the worst of him uh lions and
panthers get together peter on sunday
and there are questions about both
starting quarterbacks in that game
matthew stafford throwing again he's got
a finger problem and it seems like
there's always something that matthew
stafford is finding a way to play
through without complaint i respect that
about him
and it really is odd to see him now in
year
12 is it 12 is it 11 or 12.
it's he was drafted in 2009 i always
screw that up 2009 yeah year 12. this is
12. this is year 12 for matthew stafford
and he's just never quite fully
fulfilled his potential he's had some
great years
and the lines are just hanging around at
four and five i don't think anybody
expects them to pull their way back into
the playoff chase but no matter whether
they're in or not in relevant or not
relevant stafford always does everything
he can to find a way to play and i
expect him to play and probably play
well on sunday
i mean i think he probably will mike but
i think you're right uh if
when they expanded the playoffs i think
everybody said well you know now more
opportunity for everybody and i get that
but
i mean there's opportunity for a hot
team playing pretty consistently well
and that's the minnesota vikings i i
will be very surprised if the lions
uh can rev it up enough to make the
playoffs out of a very crowded playoff
field in the nfc
you know but if they would win this game
turn around on thursday and beat the
texans as they'll be favored to do
how rare that is for the lion's den six
and five
you know there's always that team
that is around 500 this time of year
that finds the gas pedal and mashes it
and starts rattling off and you know
right now it's the vikings but that
could end as soon as sunday when they
play the cowboys who knows but it's that
team that just strings them together in
unlikely fashion and before you know it
there they're in that discussion week 16
week 17 if they win their last two and
this team loses that team it's a problem
the nfc there's so many good teams and
one of those playoff spots is going to
be burned on a crap team from the nfc
east that it really does make it hard
for somebody who's currently below 500
or at 500 to get into the picture but
we'll see how that all plays out also in
that game the carolina panthers are the
last team you see they're in the hunt at
three and seven
and they're better than three and seven
but it's gonna be hard to get the
victory if they don't have teddy
bridgewater there was a report yesterday
from nfl media that bridgewater is not
going to play with that mcl injury he
suffered on sunday against the tampa bay
buccaneers bridgewater disputed that
nothing's been decided yet so we'll see
you know if it's not a serious mcl
strain you can stabilize the knee and
play you're running the risk that you're
going to injure it even more and for a
guy who lost two seasons to a knee
injury
you assume he's going to err on the side
of caution but i guess there's also the
chance hey i've gone enough years
without playing football i'll throw
caution to the wind let's just go play
and try to win but that's going to be a
big factor in this one as well i picked
the panthers to win under the assumption
as of yesterday that bridgewater would
be playing without him that does change
everything although i'm not going to
write them off pj walker was pretty damn
good in the xfl
if blink and you missed the xfl
and and with that connection to matt
rule i i it could be interesting but
yeah i think they're far better off if
bridgewater plays and officially for now
it hasn't been decided he'll get a
designation today questionable doubtful
or out based upon what the panthers
think he's able to do come sunday
look i i you know pj walker uh
you know robbie anderson matt rule you
know temple's gift to the nfl you know
really and all of those guys to me
um
you know have
been showing the nfl that they were
wrong i mean we'll see if pj walker gets
his shot
and if he can prove that but
mike all i can say is
it's a weird thing because you're not
around teams
but i bet five people in the panthers
organization at some point this year
from the draft to today
have basically said
if this guy ever gets a chance to play
look out so anyway we'll see
we'll see it's either going to be
bridgewater or walker and if all else
fails it's will greer and even though he
was decent at west virginia what we've
seen from him so far in his nfl career
uh let's just say the panthers hope it's
not will greer the cowboys hope it was
dak prescott but obviously that's over
andy dalton is back though he missed
time with concussion he was on the covet
19 reserve list he actually was positive
for covet 19. he now comes back to lead
the cowboys into a game against the
minnesota vikings and even though the
cowboys at two and seven are still
alive in the
nfc east i i just don't get the
impression that they realize it or that
they want to be i mean the window
continues to be open and they keep
flying into the pain
uh above the opening and i i i you know
who knows look every time we think we
know what's going on in the nfl we find
out that we don't this one looks like a
game the vikings should win their seven
point favorites peter but andy dalton is
definitely going to give them
a higher level of quarterback play than
what they've seen
in recent weeks with
the guy from
james madison whose name thankfully i've
already forgotten
ben denucci
oh no i liked it better when i didn't
remember his name
hey mike
the one thing about the cowboys is that
was the first game last week against
pittsburgh where they showed the kind of
life
on offense and defense
that we just hadn't seen since dak
prescott went down
and i mean you certainly didn't see that
on defense before last week
but the one other thing i would just say
about this team right now
i mean this
as as as you can see by looking at the
standings they obviously have a shot but
i think the biggest thing that's been
missing with the dallas cowboys
is an impactful ezekiel elliott
and to look at him and to see 3.8 yards
of carry
is just
it's it's not acceptable and obviously
you have to say man their offensive line
has been porous because it's almost new
i get it
but if that running game continues to be
as unproductive
as it has been
it's a mirage you know the cowboys have
scored 41 points in the last four weeks
that's prehistoric levels of scoring
compared to today's nfl
and i unless they get that running game
better
i don't see that that helping or that uh
improving
and they're going against the vikings
defense there really is a bunch of no
names uh and uh but they they played
well against the bears on monday night
and the cowboys we talked about the
opportunity the lions have in front of
them the cowboys can double their wins
they can match their win total through
10 weeks of the season between sunday
and thursday when they host the
washington football team if they could
pull the upset in minnesota they could
be four and seven eagles if they lose to
the browns on sunday
they uh drop another one and the giants
are off and maybe the
cowboys can can do a little something
i'm sure the nfl would love to see of
the four teams in it in the nfc east
they'd love to see the cowboys rise up
and win that division because obviously
they are the only one that draws any
real attention
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports